تواترت الادانات والاقليميه والدوليه
للانقلاب العسكري في النيجر الذي حذر
قادته من اي تدخل خارجيا في البلاد وقد
ندد مجلس الامن الدولي بالانقلاب بينما
امهل الاتحاد الافريقي منفذه اسبوعين
للتراجع عنه من ناحيتها اكدت واشنطن ان
بامكان بازوم الاعتماد عليها في مواجهه
الانقلاب الذي قال الاتحاد الاوروبي انه
لا يعترف بسلطته
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان ذاك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما الاسباب التي تقف
وراء الرفض الغربي الصارم للانقلاب في
النيجر وعلى اي نحو يمكن ان ينعكس هذا
الرفض على مواقف القوى الدوليه المناهضه
للغرب من الانقلاب وكيف يمكن ان تتطور
الاوضاع في النيجر على ضوء تصاعد الرفض
الدولي للانقلاب ومطالبه القوى الغربيه
بالتراجع عنه وما حدود الخطوات التي يمكن
ان تتخذها في مواجهته
وما العوامل التي ستحكم خطوات كل الاطراف
تجاه ما يجري في النيجر وما الاوراق
الداخليه والخارجيه التي يمكن ان يستخدمها
كل طرف اذا تطورت الاوضاع للاسوء
[موسيقى]
من مجلس الامن الدولي والاتحاد الافريقي
والاتحاد الاوروبي وواشنطن وباريس توالت
وبصيغ مختلفه ابرز الادانات للانقلاب
العسكري في النيجر والمطالبه بالافراج عن
الرئيس المعزول محمد بازوم واستعاده
النظام الدستوري رغم تاكيد قاده الانقلاب
مضيهم قدما فيه وتحذيرهم من اي تدخل عسكري
اجنبيا في البلاد
مجلس السلم والامن التابع للاتحاد
الافريقي امهل الانقلابيين في النيجر 15
يوما للعوده الفوريه وغير المشروطه الى
سكناتهم واعاده السلطه الدستوريه بينما
اكد الاتحاد الاوروبي انه لن يعترف بسلطات
الانقلاب في النيجر وان محمد بازوم هو
الرئيس الشرعي الوحيد للبلاد كما اضاف
الاتحاد انه علق دعمه المالي والتعاونه
الامني مع النيجر بشكل فوري بعد الانقلاب
وفي فرنسا التي علقت كل مساعداتها
التنمويه ودعمها للميزانيه في النيجر فورا
عقد مجلس الدفاع والامن اجتماعا برئاسه
ايمانويل ماكرون لبحث الانقلاب في النيجر
وتداعياته وتعهد ماكرون بدعم مجموعه
الاقواس سواء في جهود الوساطه او فرض
عقوبات على منفذي للانقلاب
الولايات المتحده التي تحتفظ باكثر من الف
جندي وقاعدتين لطائرات المسيره في النيجر
والتي قالت ان انقلاب النيجر سيتسبب في
توقف الشراكه معها قالت خلال اتصال هاتفي
اجراه وزير خارجيتها مع رئيس النيجر
المطاح به محمد بازوم ان بامكان بازوم
الاعتماد عليها الاستعاده النظام الدستوري
في البلاد
[موسيقى]
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا من النواكشوط
اسماعيل ولد الشيخ سيديا الكاتب والمحلل
السياسي المختص في الشان الافريقي ومن
جنيف الدكتور حسني عبيدي استاذ العلاقات
الدوليه بجامعه جنيف مرحبا بكما سيد حسني
ابدا معك
هناك اعطاء في خطاب ربما
واشنطن والاتحاد الاوروبي وايضا الاتحاد
الافريقي هناك اعطاء للمهل هناك وعود
وتعهدات للرئيس وتوعدات ايضا
للانقلابيين ترى ما الدوافع وراء هذا
الموقف
الصارم والحازم من الانقلابيين في النيجر
يعني كل الجهات التي تطرقت اليها تريد ان
يكون هناك ردا جماعيا وخاصه ردا سريعا
لعمليه الاطاحه بالرئيس محمد بازوم
بالنسبه لاتحاد الافريقي لانه هناك بند
داخل الاتحاد الافريقي يمنع
الاتحاد من الاعتراف باي نظام سياسي ياتي
اثراء انقلاب بالنسبه لفرنسا والاتحاد
الاوروبي الولايات المتحده كما تعلمين
يعني هناك اسباب قبل كل شيء سياسيه وامنيه
قويه جدا ضربت ما بين النيجر وهذه الاطراف
الثلاث وبالتالي كان لزاما عليها لان
النيجر تعتبر في هذه المنطقه اخر القلاع
ان يكون
التنديد وكذلك تهديد قويا لكن ما بين
التهديد وكيفيه التطبيق اعتقد هناك يعني
قصه اخرى سيد اسماعيل لماذا ذهب الغرب
تحديدا الولايات المتحده والاتحاد
الاوروبي وفرنسا يعني ضمن الاتحاد
الاوروبي فورا الى حسم موقفه
بهذا الوضوح بانه لن يعترف بالانقلاب هناك
ايضا خطوات عمليه فوريه مثل تعليق التعاون
الامني والمساعدات الماليه
اهلا بك سيدتي واهلا بضيفك الكريم
ومشاهدينا كارم
الواقع ان هنالك مسافه كبيره جدا بينما
يقال في العالم وما يحدث في السر بكل
تاكيد بدات الامور تتضح انه الجيش
حسم امره
واجتمع خلف قيادته منذ منذ يومين تقريبا
وبالتالي المواجهه القادمه هي ستكون مع
الجيش باكمله وليس مع مع فيلقين او لواء
على حساب فيلق اولياء وهنا مكمل الداء
النيجيريا التي يعني واضح ان هنالك تناغم
بين جهود الولايات المتحده وفرنسا
والاتحاد الافريقي والمنتظم الاقليمي
بقياده نيجيريا التي تحدها الف كيلو متر
تقريبا تزيد او تنقص قليلا مع النيجر
ويعني على حدود نيجيريا هنالك نفس القبائل
ونفس الشعوب واعتقد ان الجيش النيجيري
لجيش نيجيريا لانه هنالك تشابه في اللفظ
بين الدولتين جيشنا نيجيريا لن يجازف
بمواجهه مع النيجر بحكم انه هي نفس
التداخلات حتى الالسونيه احيانا وبالتالي
البنه هي المال البنيه يعني
تربطها يربطها انبوب كبير لنقل محروقات مع
النيجر وهي احدى المتنفسات الاطلسيه
للنيجر ولا اعتقد انها ستجاذب اما المحيط
الاخر من فهو مغضوب عليه لانه فيها اربع
دول الان ديمقراطيه واهداحشر دول
الانقلابيه و11 دوله
ديمقراطيه من بين هؤلاء من يحدهم اللي هو
مالي وبوركينا فاسو ولن تكون المواجهه مع
الجيش النيجيري منهما لان هنالك جاذبيه
وغزلا روسيا بدا يجمع الثلاثه مؤخ منذ
يومين
انه الفرنسيين هم
لديهم تقريبا
لواء من المظليين هناك وهنالك بعض المشات
يعني مجموعه 1500 جندي يمكن ان يكون العول
الافريقي على هذا هذه القوه الفرنسيه
والقوه الخاصه الامريكيه الموجوده في
اكاديس عدا عن ذلك هنالك يد ممدوده من
العسكر لفرنسا تضمن لفرنسا 33% من
اليورانيوم واعتقد ان فرنسا تقول شيئا في
العلن وستقول اشياء اخرى في السر لانها لن
تجازف باطلاق نار قرب
تمويل مبالاه على سبيل ماذا سيد اسماعيل
على كل روسيا التي يتهمها كثيرون بدعم
انقلاب النيجر او الاستعداد على الاقل
لدعمه في وجه اي ضغوط غربيه استقبل رئيسها
فلاديمير بوتين الرئيس المؤقت لمال العقيد
السيمي جويتا وقال وخلال اللقاء على روسيا
ستخصص حزمه ماليه لشراء البضائع لمالي
التي وصفها بانها شركه مهم لموسكو في
المنطقه اما جويتا فقال ان بلاده تعيش تحت
ضغوط كبيره لكنها تعول رغم ذلك على تطوير
علاقاتها مع روسيا
زعيم اخر في غرب افريقيا واتضع علاقه
بلاده مع موسكو على حساب باريس التقه
بوتين في سام بطرسبورغ هو الرئيس
الانتقالي لبوركينا فاسو ابراهيم تراوري
الذي وصف روسيا بانها الشريك الحقيقي
لبلاده سيد حسيني هنا هذا التشدد من قبل
الغرب في الموقف المناهض من الانقلاب مع
هذه التعهدات وهذه المهل التي يعطيها له
للانقلابيين في النيجر هذا التشدد الى اي
درجه سيكون عامل دفع
للانقلابيين للذهاب باتجاه روسيا حتى وان
لم تكن لديها على سبيل المثال مثلا او
الاعتقاد بان ليس لديها يد في انقلاب مثلا
النيجر سيدفع الانقلابيا باتجاهها اكثر مع
وجود مثل هذا الخط الممتد الى بوركينا
فاسو هو مالي ايضا
يعني هذا ما يخشاه الغرب بالاضافه الى ان
الولايات المتحده وخاصه فرنسا
ذهبت بعيدا في تعاونها الامني لمحاربه كما
تقول التنظيمات الارهابيه وكذلك لاسباب
اقتصاديه معروفه هناك الخوف لدى واشنطن
لدى باريس بان في النهايه الذهاب بعيدا في
العقوبات ضد النظام الجديد في النيجر
سيفتح الباب في النهايه لروسيا او كذلك
لربما لدوله اخرى اي ان النظام سيضطر في
النيجر بطلب المساعده من قبل روسيا لانه
اصبح بدون مساعدات مهمه يذكر بان فقط
الاتحاد الاوروبي صرف في ظرف ثلاث سنوات
اكثر من 556 مليون دولار
مساعده الفرنسيه هي تقريبا 120 اي ان
الغرب يعلم جيدا بان الذهاب بعيدا او
الترك النظام الحالي وحيدا وفرض المزيد من
العق يمكن في النهايه ان يذهب الى الى
موسكو النقطه الثانيه هو الخوف الكبير بان
فرنسا في النهايه ستفقد حتى الدول الاخرى
لان ستفقد مصداقيتها في المنطقه وستقول
الانظمه الافريقيه بان فرنسا لا يمكن ان
يعول عليها للحفاظ على الدول هي او
الانظمه الصديقه لباريس او حتى الصديقه
للولايات المتحده الامريكيه ولذلك فعلا
الوضع لا يحسد عليه في نفس الوقت لا يمكن
لباريس ان تترك هذا الموضوع يعني بهذه
الطريقه ولذلك انا اتفق بان هناك مفاوضات
جاريه الان
والمؤسسه لنظام الجديد في النيجر هو مطالب
بتحريك الشارع اذا اذا ظهر الشارع خرج
الشارع يقول بانه
في النهايه مع هذه السلطه الجديده من
الصعب على باريس او على اتحاد الاوروبي
الذي كان حادا جدا في انتقاده يعني
الاتحاد الاوروبا الاتحاد الافريقي لانه
في النهايه ليس مؤهل ان يعطي اي دروس في
الديمقراطيه لكن بالنسبه للاتحاد الاوروبي
وباريس والولايات المتحده هذا مهم جدا
واذا اعطيت الضمانات الكافيه الامنيه خاصه
الاقتصاديه لباريس والاحتمال الثالث هو
قضيه ان جيش يعلن بانه يبدا في مرحله
انتقاليه بمساعده بمساعده يوسف او مساعده
اخرى وبان الجيش سينصرف عن الحياه الحياه
السياسيه عندما تتشكل حكومه جديده هذه
الضمانات اعتقد ان فرنسا لن ترفضها وهنا
سيد اسماعيل كيف يمكن ان تتطور الاوضاع من
وجهه نظرك داخل النيجر خاصه مع مثلا
الحديث الغربي الذي يتحدث بان هناك حراك
شعبي رافض لمثل هذه الخطوه من قبل
الانقلابيين وحديث اخر ايضا عن يعني جهود
وساطه منتظره من قبل الاكويس قد تفضي الى
عدول مثلا عدول الانقلابيين عما قاموا به
انا اعتقد ان المفاوضات التي بداها قائد
الاستخبارات من نيجيريا قبل ثلاثه ايام
وصحبه قائد الاركان والتي لم تكتمل بعد
يعني سترسل بواكير بواكير نتائجها الى قمه
الطارئه غدا في بوشا اعتقد ان هذا هو بيت
القصيد وهذه وهذه بدايه رسم خارطه الطريق
لما بعد الاعلان اكبر خساره حتى الان يعني
اقوى نقاط الضعف عند الانقلابيين هو عدم
استقاله الرئيس بازون لانه
النموذج المالي والنموذج البركي في
استقاله ابراهيم بابا بكر كيتا تحت يعني
قيد السجن وقيد الاعتقال واستقاله الرئيس
الاسبق في بوركينا فاسوروك ماركابوري يعني
تحت فوهه فوهات
بنادق الانقلابيين هذا النموذج لم رفض
بعزم استنساخه وبالتالي احرج الانقلابيين
بشكل كبير رغم علوي رتبهم العسكريه
وضخام التجريب تجاربهم لكن بين هذا وذاك
اعتقد انه بعزم سلامه بوعزوم الشخصيه
ووجوده كدرع بشري لدى الانقلابيين هي هي
تقريبا 90% من اوراق القوه لديهم ان نجحت
عبر عمليه خاطفه في
ربما بمساعده من كوماندوز فرنسي في
استخراجه من
اللي موجوده في القصر الرئاسي فسيخسر
الانقلاب كل الاوراق اما اذا استمرت سياسه
الليل الذراع بالضغوط الاقتصاديه من اجل
استخراج فتره انتقاليه مقبوله فاعتقد ان
هذا السيناريو تكرر 200 مره منذ بزوغ
الدوله الوطنيه في افريقيا وهو المعول وهو
المال يعني سيد
حسني كيف برايك سيكون النهج او المقاربه
الفرنسيه لما يجري هي معنيه جدا في النيجر
خاصه مع ما جرى على خط دول الساحل
الافريقي الاخرى هل برايك وذكرت انت في
اجابتك السابقه سيناريوهات وفرضيات ولكن
ما هي الاقرب
لفرنسا هل تتفق مع ما ذكره السيد اسماعيل
ام ستعول اكثر على وساطه مثل وساطه
الاكواس
يعني صحيح ان عدم استقاله بزوم يعني ازمه
الوضع وصعبه المهمه في نفس الوقت وهنا
يعني خيبه الامل الفرنسيه ان
الضباط المجموعه المسلحه هي في النهايه
كانت تتعاون بشكل بشكل منتظم مع الضباط
الفرنسيين الموجودين جزء منهم في المطار
والمناسبه المطار هو المطار تقريبا هو
اداره مشتركه بين الامريكان والفرنسيين
وقوات كذلك من وقوات من النيجر يعني جزء
منهم هم الذين
طلبوا بازون من الاستقاله فبالتالي هذه
خيبه امل لانه كان دائما رهان بالنسبه
لفرنسا دائما ان تكون علاقاتها جيده مع
العسكر باعتبار ان المؤسسه العسكريه وان
الجيش يمكن ان يكون هو في النهايه دائما
هو البديل في حاله اي حاله عدم استقرار
انا اعتقد ان فرنسا ستستمر على المصارين
يعني مسار مسار انتظار خروج بازون باي
طريقه رغم ان الموجبه العسكريه اعتقد فيها
مخاطره كبيره المحافظه على حياته وهو يعني
اعتقد ضمانه بالنسبه للعسكر ومهمه مهمه
جدا
والمسار الثاني هو المسار التفاوض مع
العسكر من اجل ضمانات اعتقد هذا باريس
تريد ضمانات امنيه على استمرار من الصعب
جدا نقل 1500 عسكري فرنسي موجودين في
قاعدتين اعتقده ثلاث قواعد في النيجر في
هذا الاجر القصير وبالتالي تحتاج فرنسا
ولذلك في حتى اجتماع المجلس الدفاع تطرق
وزاره الخارجيه هي التي اخرجت بيان تقول
بان المساعده ستتوقف لم تقل تلغى ولكن
يعني وقفت لكن قليل يعني من الانباء خارج
حول ما يتعلق بالتعاون العسكري والتعاون
الامني ما بين القوات في نيامي وكذلك
القوات الفرنسيه وانا اعتقد انها ستواصل
على هذه النقطه وهي قضيه اقناع بعض
العسكريين في ايجاد مخرج يحفظ باريس وكذلك
النظام الجديد في
ترى ان هذا هو
السيناريو الذي يمكن ان تلعب عليه باريس
المهتمه جدا
بالنيجر لاسبابها يعني الاقتصاديه خاصه
ملف اليورانيوم ان تعول على توازنات
داخل المؤسسه العسكريه داخل الجيش يمكن ان
تلعب عليها من اجل تحقيق انعطافه تعيد
ربما هذه الانعطاف
الحلول الممكنه لتسويات ما بين وجود رئيس
بازوم والانقلابيين
بكل تاكيد باريسيا اشد الدول واشد الجهات
حرجا في هذه اللحظات لانه باريس يعني
تغذي مفاعلات النوويه من ارليت في النيجر
وباريس ايضا تعتبر اخر الحلفاء بعد وفاه
ادريس ديبي وبعد طردها غير
لبق من من مالي وكذلك اخراجها المتوقعه
غير المفاجئ من بوركينا فاسو وباريس تحتاج
الى الى النيجر في كل شيء
تحتاجها
كحاضنه لقواتها في في دول ساحل وتحتاجها
كذلك الاقتصادها غير ذلك هنالك هنالك
عناوين وهنالك مظاهر وتصريحات ليست
بالضروره اذا تقييم عمليه على الارض ما
قاله
له مكروه في جولته في فرنسا ما وراء
البحار وما سيقوله مجلس الاعلى للدفاع ليس
بالضروره هو ما سيحدث لان اليد الممدوده
من العسكر
اتضحت بشكل جليل المراقبين اليوم من خلال
لقاءات ومكالمات هاتفيه بينهم وبين
الدبلوماسيين الفرنسيين وكذلك
فانس كما تسمونها بالمشرق في قمتها غدا
سيحضرها اصدقاء لفرنسا وفرنسا لن تمنح
للضباط فرصه ان يظهروا بمظهر الضحيه
المعتدى عليه من قبل المستعمر السابق
معناه انه تحركات فرنسا ينبغي ان تكون
حذره جدا ولربما تحت غطاء الاكواس لانه
فرنسا هي محاضره في كل شيء في هذه
الاقاليم حتى حتى سلامه الطيران المدني هي
مساهمه في شركه عساكنا التي تسيطر على
مطارات النيجر
وهي المساهم الاكبر في هذه الشركه
الستينيات وبالتالي اعتقد انه فرنسا لديها
كل شيء وقد خسرت كل شيء وتوشك ان توزع
الاوراق من دونها ان لم تصغي باجتهاد وحسم
وحسم للطرفين للانقلابيين
الصعب لباريس هناك عين تترصد سيد حسني
دكتور حسني
موسكو هي مهتمه بالمشهد هناك برايك هل
ستنتظر الثمره كي تسقط ام انها ستذهب
وتسعى اليها لتكون
لاعب وفاعل في النيجر
يعني مما لا شك فيها ان روسيا مهتمه جدا
واعتقد انها بدات اصلا بعض
المفاوضات رئيس الاركان
الفينيامي السابق الذي طرد من قبل بزوم
لانه قال بان العلاقات ما بين نيامي وبين
بوركينا فاسو وكذلك ما بين ومع مالي لابد
ان تكون مهمه ولابد ان تكون قويه فهم ذلك
على اساس انه في النهايه يريد ان تتوسع
العلاقه الى ان تصل الى الى موسكو وتمت
اقالته واعتقد ذهب به الى سفير في احد
الدول العربيه يعني هن هناك فعلا حرج كبير
يمكن ان تقع فيه باريس روسيا مهتمه لانها
اذا استطعت ان تصل الى نيامي فانها وصلت
في النهايه الى الساحه التي وصلت الى
الحزام الاساسي لسواء دمار دول شمال
افريقيا او حتى النفوذ الفرنسي الذي ابعد
من ذلك واعتقد ان الولايات المتحده قوه
الموقف الامريكي الذي هو مع باريس هو كذلك
لانها فعلا تخشى من ان مو تجد بابا للدخول
في النيجر
شكرا لك من جنيف دكتور حسني عبيدي
استاذ العلاقات الدوليه بجامعه جنيف واشكر
ايضا ضيفي من اسماعيل ولد الشيخ سيديا
الكاتب والمحلل السياسي المختص في الشان
الافريقي شكرا جزيلا لكما على المشاركه
معنا والى هنا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من برنامج
ما وراء الخبر الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]